hemos estado trabajando muchos ejemplos
de cómo nombrar moléculas en este vídeo
vamos a ir en sentido contrario
empezaremos con el nombre y vamos a ver
cómo podríamos dibujar su estructura
molecular así que el primer ejemplo que
vamos a tratar de resolver es este que
es el 1 cíclope ntil 6 729 de
isopropílico exa decano y yo sé que al
inicio puede asustar mucho pero en
realidad no tenemos que preocuparnos
tanto es es relativamente sencillo y y
la estrategia principal es irnos
exactamente hasta el final porque aquí
está la información de nuestra
estructura central de nuestra digamos
columna vertebral de esta molécula y eso
está el digamos escrito en esta parte
donde nos dice ciclohexano ex a decano
verdad nos está diciendo primero que es
un arcano es decir esta parte de aquí
déjenme déjenme quitar este recuadro
esta parte de aquí nos está diciendo que
son ex a de acá no es son
son ex as son seis de que son diez es
decir tenemos 16 carbonos y el hecho de
que sea una al cano nos dice que hay
enlaces simples entre ellos entonces son
16 carbonos con enlaces simples verdad
no hay enlaces múltiples ahora cuál es
la siguiente parte nos dice aquí ciclo
eso nos dice que es un anillo verdad es
un anillo es una estructura digamos
justamente en ciclo verdad entonces toda
esta parte de aquí que dice ciclo ex a
decano
resume toda la información de nuestra
estructura principal así que vamos a
tratar de dibujar ese primero tenemos
aquí digamos el primero segundo déjenme
hacer lo más bonito
un tercero 4
8 estoy tratando de hacerlo lo mejor que
puedo 9
y es vamos a hacer algo así 11 12 13 14
15 y 16 y simplemente unimos esto es
verdad entonces ya tenemos aquí nuestro
ciclo ex a decano verdad y cada uno de
estos puntos que estoy digamos marcando
corresponde a un carbono muy bien y por
supuesto en este caso no importa como
enumeremos no tiene no tiene ningún
problema como enumeremos porque es
bastante arbitrario ya después veremos
dónde van acomodados nuestros grupos al
kilo así que vamos a enumerar lo por
ejemplo éste puede ser el 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 y 16 muy bien
ahora vamos a ir dibujando todos los
grupos al kilo que nos va diciendo y
primero fijémonos en este nos dice 29
y su propio muy bien en realidad el día
sale sobrando verdad nos dice que tanto
en el 2 como en el átomo 9 de carbono de
esta este de este ciclo tenemos que
encontrar un grupo hizo propio y verdad
y prop el prefijo prop se refiere a tres
átomos de carbono y cuando vemos el
prefijo eso quiere decir que es como
esta estructura verdad una estructura
como en que entonces vamos a tener esta
estructura en sí y unido a nuestro
segundo átomo de carbono lo mismo ocurre
para el átomo número 9 tenemos esta
estructura y lo unimos al átomo 9 muy
bien vámonos a la siguiente parte nos
dice el 6 útil útil
el prefijo que significa que vamos a
utilizar dos átomos de carbono verdad y
van a estar en el carbono 6 entonces
ponemos dos átomos de carbono y los
unimos al carbono 6 y finalmente vamos
analizar el 1 cíclope ntil 1 ciclo
pentium o cíclope ntil nos dice vamos a
unirlo al átomo 1 y vamos a unir
justamente un grupo ciclo penti lo
entonces ponemos un ciclo de longitud 5
verdad ahí tienen 5 átomos de carbono y
simplemente lo unimos al primer átomo de
esta cadena y ahí lo tienen simplemente
fue digamos ir trabajando este no un
nombre por pedazos verdad y ahí tenemos
ya la estructura molecular de esta de
este nombre que es bastante largo y
medio feo vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a hacer este ejemplo el 3 699 3
detrás me tildó de acá no muy bien y en
este caso vamos a hacer exactamente lo
mismo pero vamos a hacerlo un poco más
rápido la estructura central es el dow
decano lo de acá no es un arcano puros
enlaces simples pero tenemos 12 átomos
de carbono verdad entonces vamos a
pintarlo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 ya
sabemos que la enumeración es bastante
arbitraria verdad entonces pues podemos
empezar de izquierda a derecha aquí va
el 8 9 10 11 12 verdad y ahí tenemos
nuestra cadena principal que es el dow
decano y ahora vamos a agregar cuatro
grupos metilo y nos dicen donde en el 36
y dos veces en el 9 entonces en el
carbono 3 agregamos sólo o más bien
unimos un átomo de carbono verdad de
esta forma en el carbono 6
exactamente lo mismo y nos dice que en
el carbono 9 hay que agregar 2 verdad y
esto es válido porque los carbonos
tienen 4 enlaces posibles aunque el
derecho tienen que cubrir los 4 enlaces
y ahí tenemos 4 grupos metilo unidos a
esta cadena principal de digamos de 12
átomos de carbono y este fue bastante
sencillo vámonos al último ejemplo
vámonos al último ejemplo y que es este
el 13 bis 11 de metil etil ciclo pantano
entonces antes de que te asustes respira
profundo tranquilízate porque realmente
es muy sencillo y vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo entonces primero
tenemos que nuestra nuestra estructura
principal es el ciclo pentano verdad
entonces tenemos un ciclo de 5 átomos de
carbono ahí está nuevamente la
enumeración es arbitraria digamos
empezamos aquí 1 2
345 verdad luego qué es lo que nos dice
vamos de hecho tenemos aquí una
estructura más complicada verdad tenemos
el 11 de metil etil y bis es decir en
aquí aquí vamos a tener esta estructura
lo vamos a tener esta estructura en el
carbono 1 y en el carbono 3 verdad por
eso elvis esto es porque estamos usando
la nomenclatura sistemática entonces en
cada uno de estos debe repetirse esta
estructura el 11 y metil etil entonces
nos fijamos primero en la parte de till
en la parte de till significa que
tenemos dos átomos de carbono verdad dos
átomos de carbono
ahora qué es lo que nos dice la otra
parte de esta parte de aquí nos dice
dimetil y él dimetil está en el 11 es
decir si sí enumeramos digamos aquí 1 2
1 2 entonces estamos diciendo el 1 que
es con el que se conecta a nuestra
estructura principal y nos dice nos dice
que hay dos grupos metilo en el primer
carbono entonces aquí tenemos dos grupos
metilo dos grupos metilo verdad y ahí lo
tenemos ya tenemos exactamente cuál es
la estructura molecular de este nombre
que en principio parecía bastante o más
bien muy poco amigable verdad y por
supuesto esto estuvo en nombre o más
bien con la nomenclatura sistemática
pero esta estructura de este este grupo
al kilo que de hecho estos dos grupos al
kilo que son iguales que salen de
nuestro ciclo pentano en realidad tienen
otro nombre de verdad este carbono es un
carbono terciario porque está unido a
otros tres carbonos
está unido después a nuestra cadena oa
nuestro ciclo principal entonces este de
aquí es un grupo de útil ser útil verdad
estos dos son grupos zerbouti los
entonces el nombre digamos
la nomenclatura común para esta misma
molécula sería la siguiente en vez de
poner mis 11 de metil etil sería el
siguiente sería 13 porque se encuentran
en el carbono 1 y 3 y en este caso sería
d
ser útil que a veces lo podemos dejar
solo como te dé útil ciclo pantano
verdad simplemente sustituimos este esta
esta parte que está en nomenclatura
sistemática por la nomenclatura común y
ahí lo tienen no sólo encontramos la
estructura molecular sino que además
hasta pudimos dar el nombre común para
esta molécula